First of all, really quickly I have a picture to show you.
I did the cover of In Style,
I shot it myself during the pandemic
and I posed for a picture.
And so those are Good American jeans
and I just wanted to tell you
I think it's the best jeans company in the world.
I love it so much.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, that's so nice of you, thank you!
You look awesome and you shot it, oh my God.
Thank you and I, after having two children,
well, I don't look the same in jeans.
It's a different era in my life.
46 and two kids, I'm not in my twenties, you know.
I don't have that body anymore
and putting on your jeans,
I feel good about myself
and I wanna thank you
because you've like.
Oh my gosh.
Really.
That's so, so nice of you.
And you know, that was one of the reasons why me
and my business partner, Emma,
we decided to make Good American
is because I,
my weight has always fluctuated my whole life
and we wanted to be all inclusive
and going up to a size 24 at the time
was really important to us
and whoever wanted to carry our brand,
they had to carry the same,
the full size range and never separate the size range.
I never wanted someone to feel, you know,
isolated again and like oh,
you have to be ushered up to a different floor.
So that was one of the main reasons
why we started Good American.
I'm a giant fluctuator too
and then I had two kids
and then I was like oh God,
now this is the body I have to shop for clothes with?
Oh my gosh, you are.
And then I was like all right,
you need to start exercising
and I think I needed that outlet
and I've been so inspired by you
who talk about working out as something
that's like such a good mental outlet
as well as physical.
It's so weird because in my,
I'm a little different.
In my twenties I think I was chubbier
and then I got a divorce I think at 29
and I really needed an outlet
and I needed, I just turned to the gym
and it started really slow
and now it's really religious for me,
I do it super early in the morning
before my daughter wakes up.
It's a way to start my day.
I feel so good, I feel mentally clearer
and I will tell you,
when I'm upset, when I'm sad, when I'm angry,
those workouts are so beast.
I am like, I'm an animal in there.
So I know how therapeutic the gym can be for me
and if I didn't have that,
I would probably be a monster throughout my day
and it's really my form of therapy
and I just feel so accomplished
and badass after the gym.
I don't know if this is assuming
because I hate assumption
and I'm not an assuming person,
but from a person watching your journey
from afar who doesn't know you,
you always seem to like take your whole thing
with like physical wellness as like
a really independent for no one else but yourself.
It was sexy and empowered
and it always had the right messaging to me.
Thank you.
I mean, and you know this way more than I do,
especially, in the world that this is,
it's so, people criticize you
and tell you you're fat even if you're not
and you start to believe you're fat,
like there are so many things that
instead of people giving you compliments
or just say nothing at all.
It's really so easy to fall victim to okay,
I'm just gonna go on a crash diet
because I have to lose 20 pounds
because some magazine called me fat or something
and because of my family,
I never felt any of the things that
people would say about me.
I don't know why.
I guess I had this I think
just like a force field of protection around me
through positive words and love through my family
and I always attest that like I went on
my physical wellness journey when
it was my time to do so.
You have to be willing and ready
and you have to be able
and just, you have to want to, you have to,
because it's a lifestyle.
I don't, I don't really believe in diets,
I believe in eating healthy
and I believe in making lifestyle changes
and it took a lot of inner strength
for me to do things on my terms
when I was ready and in my way
because I felt like that was the healthiest way.
Yeah, no, it is.
And at one point you were like I was 29,
I was getting divorced, you know,
I had a coping mechanism
and I was gonna be like it's food, right?
That was mine.
And you were like and I went to the gym
and I was like oh.
That was not.
No, food was my coping mechanism.
I wish that was my coping mechanism.
I need it to be my coping mechanism.
I'm better about it now.
Definitely, I found my balance.
Yeah and you know what,
food used to be my coping mechanism.
You know, when my dad died, so many things,
but I had to go through that
and learn okay, yes,
the food mechanism felt so good for the moment,
but then afterwards I would feel so bad about myself.
But you have to experience it
and I had to go through that
and like I said be willing and able,
like okay, so I tried the food coping situation
for a couple years
and that didn't make me feel good.
In fact, it made me probably a little more depressed
and made me feel bad about myself
and then, you know,
so it took me years to figure out
what made me actually get through
a really challenging time in my life in a healthy way.
Do you think that is what growing up is
because lately I've been like for the first time in my life
like growing up isn't overrated,
it's kind of awesome.
It is.
It's awesome and you know,
I used to be, of course,
I don't think any of us love to get older,
but sometimes I look back at my twenties
and I'm like oh.
I love that I had my daughter in my thirties.
I wanted to have kids so badly in my twenties
and it didn't happen
and there's a reason for everything
and I'm, you know,
but you get to then I'm like I'm so happy I got to live
and experience my twenties
and you're just, it's so cliche,
but like I'm older and wiser
and I'm more confident
and you kind of just are more comfortable with who you are
and maybe more comfortable saying no
then I probably was in my twenties
so I do think getting older is a really beautiful thing
and you can make it a really negative thing.
I'm all for how you, perspective on everything,
and I'm gonna choose to make this
a really beautiful thing, getting older.
Well I love hearing your perspectives
and you've partnered with Dose & Co.
to tackle some of those issues
that result from pregnancy.
We're talking about the body.
Now this is about hair
and I loved so much that you are doing non-plastic.
Thank you so much because if someone like you does it,
it's gonna start a huge chain reaction
and this is what we need to raise our kids
on a safe planet.
Please tell me about it
and thank you for making that choice
because you're gonna change the game for people.
So the no plastic thing is a huge,
no single use plastic is something
I really try to do as much as possible
and Dose & Co. I actually found,
I was, just finished breastfeeding,
I started losing my hair,
especially in like this area after breastfeeding.
I tried a couple collagen companies or brands
and you know, nothing was really working.
I was kinda like is this,
I don't know, it just wasn't working for me.
I kinda thought it was bogus
and someone suggested Dose & Co.
At the time they were only in New Zealand
and someone sent me something
and I tried it
and in 30 days I kid you not
I noticed a significant difference
in my hair, skin, and nails.
So I, being the dork that I am,
I wrote them an email
and I was like hey, I love your products,
would you guys start selling to the US.
I'm such a dork.
And they were just blown away
that I even knew about their company
and then they flew out here to the United States,
we had meetings and I,
we just really hit it off.
I loved what the company stood for
and everything is there's no fillers
and no artificial anything.
It's as pure as you can get.
We have eight different product lines in it.
We have pure collagen
and it's just good for your hair,
your skin, your nails, acne, eczema, psoriasis,
it's just good for your joints.
There's really no downside to collagen.
I love that you're doing this.
I love that you have a good perspective
and thank you so much.
It's a real pleasure to talk with you.
It's so nice talking to you to
and thank you so much for having me on
and just for sharing your stories with me.
Thank you!
Say hello to the whole family
and obviously "Keeping Up with the Kardashians"
airs Thursday at eight, seven Central on E
and it's Swan's Song season.
I am convinced you guys have a plan B.
Like you're the Kardashians.
What's coming up next?
We always have a plan B.
I knew it.
(upbeat music)